i want to have that
that long-term goal so
embedded in my mind that i never lose
sight of it
so many people don't use the strategic
12 months that they are given each year
to grow most people set goals but they
don't
create a plan on how they're going to
get there want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the five
goal setting habits that you need to
develop
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one take action
daily with jocko willing it can be
pretty easy to focus
on the battle that's right in front of
your face
and when you're doing that sometimes you
can
lose track of the the long-term goal
but i want to have that
that long-term goal so
embedded in my mind that i never lose
sight of it
ever and those little tasks and projects
and
short-term goals that you tackle they
need to lead toward
that strategic victory
winning the long war
and we get very caught up in
instant gratification we want results
now
we want the shortcut to the winner's
podium
and sometimes you know when we don't get
that
short-term glory that we want we
lose track of those long-term goals
and you you look up in in six weeks
or in six months or in six years
and you've made no progress
none you never moved
you might even be further from your goal
than you were
why why
did you let that happen
it's because you lost sight of that
long-term goal
and at some point after you lose sight
of that goal
and years have gone by you think to
yourself
maybe i can't
maybe i can't do it
and so you give up you let it
fade
and you settle
you settle for mediocrity you settle for
average you
settle for oh well
but no no
don't do that embed that long-term goal
in your mind burn it into your soul
think about it and write about it and
talk about it and hang it up on your
wall
but most important do something about it
do something about it every day every
day
do something that moves you toward that
goal
that keeps the goal alive and in sight
and in focus
however however small
or insignificant that step might seem
take it
do it to that little piece
make it happen
because that goal
isn't going to achieve itself
it's all on
you habit number two use your calendar
with brendan burchard
so many people don't use the strategic
12 months that they are given
each year to grow to live a better
quality of life to reach that next level
of joy and achievement and fulfillment
and connection
it's like why don't they use it you look
at their calendar and it's it's busy
work you know there's a lot of like
go here grab that take the kids here or
go to that game
but it's not used to develop themselves
does that make sense
they use it to they use a calendar to
record simple tasks
but there's no big picture they don't
enter the year as an example
looking 12 months out and saying wow
what kind of person do i want to be at
the end of this year
what do i want to have achieved felt
accomplished connected with
contributed and because of that their
life actually feels like a big random
bag
of tasks and activities they tend to
feel a little lost or directionless
even if they are busy because sometimes
they're just not really growing
they're just doing a lot you know
they're not really experiencing things
that they purposely chose
proactively they're just reacting to the
world's needs
and so they start to feel like a cog in
a machine versus an
independent conscious human and so let's
figure this out
how can you use this more strategically
every single month
set a monthly challenge for yourself a
monthly personal development challenge
this is related to your virtues
so for example you say you know what
january that's gonna be my month
of patience february that will be my
month of listening to other people
uh march that's gonna be my month to be
kinder than i've ever been kind
the next month is gonna be the time that
i'm gonna journal all month whatever
it's going to be i want you to have this
sort of rhythm in your life where every
30 days
you have a personal challenge to make
yourself a better human
and i can share with you this is my 19th
year
of having a personal challenge to make
myself better
and make myself better in my
relationships or my personal life or my
health
but every 30 days i have a goal and that
every 30 days
keeps my life feeling uh you know like
it's growing like i'm challenging myself
like i'm learning i don't i'm not always
finished those 30 days feeling like i
mastered those areas
but i got better at them you know and i
think we all have to be on that process
of mastery throughout the year and if we
can just set up little things like that
every month it's just
it's a nice utilization of the calendar
just say okay it's the first of the
month
here's my challenge this month every day
you journal on that challenge you see
how you're doing
the end of the month you say great
here's how i did and even if you didn't
do a good job doesn't matter
move on to the next challenge then go
through that every 12 months different
challenge every month you can recycle
them the next year if you want to
but i think that's how we really become
better humans is using that calendar
it's just a convenient way look our our
calendars all change
you and me we both have a new month
coming up what are you going to do in
this next month
what are you going to strive for how is
your health going to be next month
how are your personal relationships
going to be next month what are you
going to contribute and create next
month
what do you really want to feel next
month how is next month
going to continue to grow your maturity
your consciousness your joy your
fulfillment
by asking that question you start
looking for a better quality of answer
by looking for a better quality of
answer and striving to get there
you feel more joyous more fulfilled more
of what we call
the charge life all right my friend evan
carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
habit number three create a plan with
john assaraf
there's an old saying that says a goal
without a plan
is just a dream and most people set
goals but they don't create a plan on
how they're gonna get
there and so what i would like you to
think about is this if you were going
you know on a trip let's say you got ten
thousand dollars as a windfall
and you're going to go on a trip what
would you
decide to do on that trip well
you'd probably first decide where you
wanted to go so that would be the what
you'd probably have all the reasons why
you wanted to go that specific location
but wouldn't you also start to find out
about what
you could do there and what you could do
there
are the options for
creating the fun amazing experience that
you would want
and for every goal that you have
you have to come up with strategies of
how can you
achieve that goal and with the
strategies
you come up with timelines and
strategies
are basically what is it that you can
do to achieve that goal
so for example if you want to
lose 10 pounds that's the goal what you
can do is exercise four days a week and
eat a super healthy diet and if you
set goals with what specifically you can
do
within a timeline what happens from a
neurological perspective
is you're giving your brain a
path to follow that is based on
something that i call fractional goal
achievement
fractional goal achievement and if you
take any big goal
or smaller goal and you break it down
into smaller chunks
for the day the week the month
what you're doing to help your brain not
get overwhelmed
is showing it a path that it can follow
and when you give your brain a timeline
of what you want to do
by a certain time it actually will help
you
prioritize things in a way
that will not cause it to be overwhelmed
habit number four
set a specific goal with dan lok when it
comes to goal setting
number one you have to be very specific
and you cannot be big so making money
that's a wish
that's a dream a goal is i want to make
a hundred thousand dollars in income
by the end of the year or in the next 12
months right that's
a goal it has to be very specific and
very precise
so let's take money because it's the
easiest
let's say your goal is to make a hundred
thousand dollars in the next 12 months
what you want to do is the first verse
very first secret
what i always do is i would reverse
engineer so whatever goal that i have i
said that's my goal
i want to reverse engineer and break
that down into
what do i need to do what do i need to
focus on what skills do i need to
upgrade because usually
if when you have a goal that you need to
learn and upgrade your skills
or upgrade your your mental capacity
because
chances are whatever that you're capable
of
right now your skill your mentality
gives you this kind of result
but if you want to get to the next step
the next level
chances are you're gonna have to to be
better to learn more to become more
so once i reverse engineer i'll break
down
break that down into 12 months so on a
monthly basis
what do i need to do so let's say you
take you know i want to make 100 000
you're divided by 12 months then you
divide it by okay
every week what do i need to do so i
would break it down into monthly income
i would divide it up into
into weekly income then it'll break down
into your daily goal
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is manifest with lisa nichols your life
is a physical manifestation of the
conversation going on in your head
i'ma start with that can we just speak
for like 24 hours on this
i love this right your life is a
physical manifestation of the
conversation going on in your head
so if you said nothing but thought
everything your life is gonna show up
to make your thoughts true see you have
one job you have one job in your life
for you
to make what you think about life truth
so that you're not wrong you don't wanna
walk around wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong you want to be right about
the life you see
so you're going to work hard work
hard to produce the life that you talk
about in your mind
whether that life is no one loves me i'm
all alone you can be in a group of
people and you will think i'm so alone
and and and you will feel alone and
things will show up
to cosign your loneliness just because
you're looking for that
and so um if you start with i'm gonna
say the mind like the mind is that thing
the mind is the core
engine it starts all things it shuts all
things down
when i start thinking something
different like hold on stop i wanna
think something
i shut down that behavior i shut down
that outcome when i burst something
i birthed it in my mind i focus on my
mind i
see myself there in my mind before i got
on with you i was doing guided
visualizations
i'm recording them so people and i mean
they're juicy
and i'm saying see yourself here because
if you can see
it and then the the key is evoke the
emotion
as if you were there yep right
and that's why people are who are sad
all the time are
sad because they're thinking of things
that make them sad
and then the emotion follows the thought
so i must say everything starts with
your thought louis
but let me just say this when you speak
you speak your future into the world you
speak
your feel whatever you say whatever
falls off your tongue
when when you say i am right
the unconscious mind says and you are so
whatever comes on the other side
of that now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
when you don't feel motivated remember
your big why and your little why
your big why is your big mission it's
the reason why you're doing what you're
doing
it's the better world that you're trying
to create it's that huge
giant problem that you're trying to
tackle for the world so that it never
exists again that's your big why but
sometimes the big y is too big sometimes
you look at that big y and say who am i
to be able to go off and do that
that's some crazy big scary mission that
sometimes feels inspiring but other
times just feels like it's impossible
but you're never going to be able to do
it because you're just one
individual that's where the little why
comes in that's why the little why
becomes super helpful for you
the little why is the individual that
you helped recently
the little y is that one customer that
you helped yesterday
the little why are the comments that
come up on your youtube videos or
instagram
the little why makes you feel like i may
not be able to change the world
that big vision of mine maybe today
feels like it's too overwhelming and
impossible
but i know i helped one person i know i
helped that one person i know my message
i know my product i know my service
helped that one person feel better get a
result
today and so if i can help that one
person and i can get up and do it again
tomorrow
and do it again tomorrow it's worth it
big why
little why now i'm a big fan of routines
i'm a big fan of
not waking up like an accident i'm a big
fan of
when you wake up every day that
motivation might be gone you might have
had massive fire the day before because
you did something amazing and then you
wake up the next day and you're almost
starting from scratch
and so i think most people wake up
without a powerful routine to set them
up they don't chart their start they
wake up like an accident
and so if the big white little white
concept works for you it makes sense
then put it into your morning routine
this is how i used to start my day every
day when i first started helping
entrepreneurs i did it through speaking
through workshops
i didn't have a youtube channel i don't
even know if youtube existed when i
first started
doing this and so i wouldn't get a lot
of feedback like now i'm spoiled now you
guys leave hundreds of comments every
day and it's amazing i just have to go
to my youtube channel and see
oh another comment another comment and
it's awesome and i love it and it's so
easy to stay on top
but when i first started that didn't
exist i would do a workshop and have
such amazing feedback but then i may not
do another workshop for a month
and so how do you stay motivated from
one workshop to the next
instead of just having one spike and
then falling flat for a month until the
next spike
what i used to do was i made a
powerpoint file
and in that powerpoint file i would play
a song that i really liked
and then i would show some of the
feedback that would come up from my past
workshops from people who filled out the
form from people who emailed me who
thanked me
i showed those comments on my powerpoint
file as i listened to songs that i liked
and it just reminded me it was a daily
reset the daily reminder that the work
that i do matters
that i matter that i'm bringing value
that i'm i'm
having an impact that i'm touching lives
that i need to keep going
because when you feel like the big why
is too crazy and big it's an issue of
self-worth you feel like you're not
worthy
and so reminding yourself that the work
that you do matters
is really important every morning if you
wake up and feel like you don't matter
it's really impossible to go off and
create something amazing
and so how do you retrain your mindset i
did it that way
now i'm spoiled again now i wake up and
one of one of the things i do daily is i
look at my youtube comments i look at my
instagram comments and i see
all the love that comes in as well as a
few comments with with hate slash
suggestions as well which i appreciate
but you need to find a way to feel like
you are bringing value
that the work that you do matters and so
waking up and reminding yourself that
you're on a big mission
that there's this big problem that
you're trying to solve your big why
there's an injustice in the world that
you were going to go off and make better
and at the same time remembering all the
people that you
helped whether it was yesterday whether
it was in the past week the past month
the past year
that you may not be able to have the
impact that you want to have on a global
scale yet
but you know that you helped one person
and you helped another person and if you
can help one person
then it's worth continuing and that
today you need to get up
and go help another person and continue
the mission
[Music]
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want to learn how to set
goals and never give up check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
[Music]
there